اللي بنسمعه اخر الليل قناه تقفلوا يزعجنا
هذا جدا مهم التون اللي بنسمعه رقم
التلفزيون ويثبته هذه
[موسيقى]
مدثر محمد عبد الرؤوف
مهندس همم استديوهات ونقل خارجي وكثير من
الشباب الان في السوق همم السوق النقل
التلفزيون الرياضي همم كلام ذاتي والحمد
لله عددهم صار كبير فاحنا اليوم الاثنين
22 فانا لي 20 سنه مهندس استديوهات الخارج
[موسيقى]
المشاهد لما يكون في البيت بيتفرج على
مسلسل او على برنامج او على لعبه رياضيه
كره قدم او العاب اولمبيه او اي شيء هو
بيتفرجوا على الحدث وما يعرف كم الاجهزه
والناس اللي اشتغلوا وراء هذا الشيء
الاجهزه بتكون كثيره والمشغلين كثيرين
والمهندس هو مفتاح الربط بين كل هذول عشان
المشاهد يقدر يشوف شيء في بيته مريح العين
يعني فريق العمل التلفزيوني انا دائما
بحبه بدايره لازم تغلق كل الاطراف ولازم
يكونوا صح والا الدائره هتفلت منهم
والمنتج ما حيطلع سليم ومفتاح ربط هذول
كلهم بيكون مهندس حق النقل التلفزيون
الاقمار الصناعيه عباره عن
تشبيه لا هي عباره عن مرايه
الحدث اللي يحصل في الارض يوصل للقمر
الصناعي وينزل ينعكس من القمر الصناعي
للناس في بيوتها المرايه هذه اللي قلنا
عليها مرايا بتكون متقسم قنوات ام بي سي
حاجه واحده روتانا حاجزه واحده كل قناه
تلفزيونيه حاجزه واحده ما ينفع اللي تحت
يرسل على تردد غير صح غير تردده
وهذا اللي مثلا شفناه في كاس العالم 2010
كان في قنوات بتقطع وقت التصوير انا اذا
واطلع العرب سات اليوم اتصل بهم اقول لهم
ابغى اطلع على قمر عربسات يوم السبت من
الساعه واحده للساعه 2:00 يقوموا يعطوني
تردد معين بوقت معين وادفع فلوسه احنا
الكره الارضيه
في في مدار عليه الاقمار الصناعيه مرصوصين
جنب بعض كلهم قمر الصناعي فوق بيمشي بنفس
سرعه الارض
وبالتالي يصير القمر مثلا فوق نايل سات
فوق ومصر طول الوقت طول ما الارض بتدور
وهو بيدور فوق القاهره
الان احنا قلنا القمر الصناعي
متقسم
قنوات كل قناه لها حيز
الحيز هذا بيستقبل منه مثلا قناه العربيه
تطلع تخبط في القمر تنزل للناس في بيوتها
طيب اليوم القناه حدثوا اجهزتهم
واختاروا بدل ما يكون الديجيتال يصيروا hd
فساره القناه هذه اللي كانوا حاجزينها طول
عمرهم صارت صغيره عليهم
بياناتهم كبرت ويحتاج قناه اكبر عشان تثير
كليه الصوره وجودتها عند المشاهد افضل
فيكلم عربسات يقولوا له كبر لنا
والله لا ما ينفع انا هقول لكم على سلطه
الكبير هذا فيقوم يبلغوا الناس يوم التردد
حقنا راح هنا
[موسيقى]
خلينا نتكلم احنا في ملعب
صورنا المباراه بنصورها مباشر الستلايت
بيرسلها للقمر فين بتنزل بتنزل لمركز
القناه
يركب اللوجو ولو عنده شريط اعلانات تحت
بيركبوا اعلانات في النصف بين الشوطين
استوديو هينقل المهم الحدث بيطلع من
الموقع على الستلايت يطلع ينزل يروح مركز
القناه يضاف عليه هذه الاشياء
ويروح لمركز التشفير ويدخل في باقه ويرسل
ثاني للناس فبيطلع وينزل مرتين ستلايت
هذه العمليه ممكن تاخر البث ثلاث ثواني او
خمس ثواني بس مو اكثر
تخيلي احنا مثلا بنصور
استقبال الملك للمنتخب
ونقول له معلش طال عمرك الارسال قطر خفيف
لكل شيء بديل لكل شيء بديل لكل شيء بديل
لانه ما ينفع يقطع النقل الخارجي للاحداث
المهمه والاحداث الرياضيه بالذات
بيكون عندنا بكب بلال دائما
اوقات كثيره الكاميرات نعمل لها كاميرات
اضافيه كاميرا هذه لو فلتت في كاميرا
بديله لها
الكهرباء
بدل بدل مصدر الكهرباء نحط ثلاثه
الكيلر عباره عن ايش
سبع الوان الطيف يبدا من الابيض وينتهي
بالاسود
وباقي الالوان كل واحد له مقاس
فعشان مركز البث مثلا خلينا نتكلم احنا
قناه قبل ما نبدا بث لازم احنا نرسل لهم
كلر من الاستديو لمركز الاستقبال يشوفوه
ويجيسو
ويتاكدوا انه كل الالوان طالعه من هذا
الاستديو سليمه
وهذا يعني انه كل كاميراتهم هتعطينا صوره
سليمه اليوم بعد كده يقول لي سمعني وان
كيلو
هيرتزون اللي بنسمعه رقم التلفزيون
[موسيقى]
مره كان نهائي
في جده اتذكر
واحد الجماهير ما سوى شيء طريف برضو سوى
شيء غلط
كانوا الشباب ايامها يتحدوا مين ينزل
الملعب يجري
دائما تشوف في المباريات واحد من الجماهير
يفلتي نقطه الاسوار بطريقه ما وينزل يجري
في الملعب هذا نط ونزل جري الملعب كله
وسريع الولد ورجع ثاني
ثبتنا له كاميرات بعد ساعات كبيره جدا
فضل التراب ممكن اربع ساعات
وهو يغير مكان ويغير ملابسه ويغطي شعره
غير كل شيء يقدر يغيره
ونحن مطلعينه على الهواء طول الوقت وطبعا
الجيل التليفونات من اصحابك يروح يغير
المكان
هي اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل
[موسيقى]
احنا بنصور احداث مباشره
في ما نقدر ما نقدر نكون اجتماعيا مع
الناس طول الوقت ما نقدر نكون مع اولادنا
في العيد مثلا
يعني ما اتذكر اني ذبحت في عيد الاضحى مع
اولادي من سنين طويله يكون في الحج نفسه
قاعد اصور يكون اصور احتفالات العيد عيد
الفطر نفس الموضوع بس هذا المهنه فيها
فيها شيء
فيها نكهه سريه
يعني في مهن كثيره غير شغلنا هذا بتعطي
رواتب افضل
والدوام فيها اريح
لكن هذه ما ادري فيها شيء بيخلي اللي
يشتغل ما يقدر يبطل ادمان فيها ادمان لانه
فيها عدم بروتين كبير انا يوم مصور سباق
كره قدم
في مسجد
مقابله جميله بصراحه انا قلت لك يعني انا
ما عمري كنت قدام الكاميرا ابدا ابدا حتى
في حياتي كلها لما يجي يقولوا منصور
اه لا تمام الحمد لله الموضوع مريح
الله يعافيك